this video is sponsored by fabulous the
first 500 people to use the link in the
description will receive 25 off a
premium subscription
it started as a normal night a young
woman named Claire was out with a couple
friends and her boyfriend in Austin
Texas the group had a few drinks at one
of their apartments in downtown and then
went out to a couple of bars in the area
from here however things would suddenly
and severely turn bad
the next thing Claire knew she was
opening her eyes to Stark lighting that
overwhelmed and blinded her it was
almost as if she was being born and
seeing light for the first time as her
vision returned she noticed her
surroundings a stair aisle mostly empty
white room she was in a bed her head was
pounding there was a woman in the corner
of the room but Claire didn't recognize
her in a Delirious confusion she leaned
her head up and looked around Claire the
woman in the corner shouted as she
noticed the woman rushed to the door of
the room and gestured outside of it
almost immediately a doctor rushed in
and began assisting Claire checking her
Airways adjusting various medical
equipment and administering medications
after some time passed the doctor asked
Claire how she was feeling and what she
remembered Claire paused for a moment
I I don't know why she said
you've been in a coma for several days
you hit your head don't worry though
everything will be okay just try to
relax things should start coming back to
you more and more and we'll be here to
help you and explain everything the
doctor paused
I'm gonna let you be with your mother
for a little while
the woman who was in the corner of the
room approached Claire's bed how are you
feeling sweetie she asked I I don't know
weird I think Claire responded Claire's
mother went on to describe what happened
she told Claire that she was at a bar
with two friends named Shannon and Mary
and her boyfriend Chris when someone
tried to fight Mary but Claire stepped
in and tried to protect her in the
process Claire got hit in the head
knocking her unconscious and causing her
to fall and hit her head on the ground
the smack against the ground severely
injured her brain and she was rushed to
the hospital where she had remained in a
coma for the following six days
Claire didn't remember any of it she had
no idea what happened but far far
scarier she couldn't remember anything
at all
she didn't recognize her mom she didn't
remember anyone her mom mentioned she
didn't remember having a boyfriend she
couldn't really remember anything from
before waking up just moments ago
she had no idea who she was
it was like she had been reborn but with
an ability to think and understand
language and Concepts it was an
experience that if she had a stronger
reference point for how she felt before
and knew what she had now lost it would
have psychologically broken her
Claire spent the following couple days
resting and going through assessments
treatments and therapies after several
days had gone by and Claire's memory
hadn't returned at all the doctor
eventually concluded that Claire had
developed what is known as retroactive
Amnesia far worse than he had originally
expected he explained to Claire and her
mother that this particular condition
was known to affect episodic
autobiographical and declarative memory
which were essentially responsible for
remembering events people contextual
Frameworks and essentially who someone
was and what their life was like however
it often doesn't affect the individual's
procedural memory which involved things
like skills and language comprehension
and so Claire wouldn't have a difficult
time learning new information moving
forward but she would essentially have
to relearn everything about her life
about herself
after receiving the news Claire sat
quietly in the hospital room with her
mother her mother cried for a while
Claire felt very little struggling to
understand the emotions of the situation
eventually after some more time passed
Claire looked over to her mother and
said can I ask a question sure of course
honey what do you need
who am I like what am I like her mother
stood up and walked over toward the bed
okay sure that's an easy one you're
quiet always been a little on the shy
side closed off a bit but you know
exactly what you like and want you
always love spending time with your
friends and going out and doing things
you like extravagant big things
especially big events and luxurious
experiences you're sweet and you would
never hurt or bother or annoy or upset
anyone you don't like to waste time or
involve yourself in useless or dumb
things like a fight for example
obviously you got caught up in the
middle of something but you stood up for
your friend so that says a lot about who
you are
Claire later head back and looked
straight up as if trying to remember or
perhaps absorb her mother's words vague
threads of memory seem to appear in her
Consciousness but what were attached on
the other sides remained hung down into
the shadows of her mind
later that day Claire's sister Sammy
came in to visit her after talking for a
little while Sammy said if I know you at
all you definitely started that fight
Sammy laughed a bit then continued
you've always been a shitster you know
that always ready to fight
the next day Claire's boyfriend Chris
came in to visit giving her mother some
much needed time to go home and rest
without worrying as much Chris sat at
the edge of the hospital bed holding
Claire's hand they talked for a little
while though they had a difficult time
finding exactly what to talk about
in the midst of a silence Claire looked
at Chris and said can you tell me who I
am and what I'm like Chris paused for a
moment clearly overwhelmed well you
firstly you're incredibly beautiful and
sweet more generally you like your alone
time you prefer the simple things in
life like to just spend time by yourself
or a night in you love pasta and wine
you're a bit impulsive and often kind of
like to throw caution to the wind when
making decisions he paused for a moment
carefully thinking to himself then he
unintentionally gestured a sort of why
not look you're also kind of defensive
kind of kind of feisty which I
personally love about you you always say
how you feel but you also kind of like
starting things sometimes like to see
what reactions you can get out of people
in situations sometimes you go out over
your head like the fight sometimes you
start things with people and it's an
innocent thing initially but but it can
get carried away
there was a brief silence I started the
fight Claire said yeah did your mom not
tell you what happened no she did but
just differently I think I mean I saw
the whole thing you and Mary went up to
these two girls at the bar because you
guys thought they looked at you weird
even though they didn't one of them just
kind of looked at you guys casually but
like you were just in front of them and
then you egged them on and when they
finally pushed back you guys pushed back
further and then you all started
fighting Claire suddenly laid her head
back confused and disoriented but you're
an incredible person Claire and an
incredible girlfriend and I love you
more than anything
two days later Claire's friend Mary came
in and visited her the two sat in the
room alone while Mary reminisced over
things from their past after a little
while Claire asked her can I ask you
something sure yeah Mary said
can you describe what I'm like
who am I immediately Mary answered
you're tough as hell outgoing
adventurous confident not willing to
take anyone's [ __ ] you're my girl been
best friends ever since high school
always down to drink and go out and have
a good time down for anything honestly
Mary laughed you're easy going love to
take risks and try new things super fun
and you're an incredible friend you
stood up for me when those girls tried
to fight me so there's that hesitantly
Claire said back
so someone tried to fight you yeah this
girl wanted to fight me over like
nothing and you tried to stop the whole
thing but they just kept escalating it
but you had my back the whole time
later that same day Shannon Claire's
other friend who was there that night
came to visit
again at some point Claire asked Shannon
can you tell me what I'm like and what
happened sure yeah well firstly you're
incredibly kind and smart I met you in a
personal finance course in college and I
feel like I knew exactly who you were as
soon as I met you pragmatic calculated
careful you don't just do things
haphazardly you're thoughtful about
risks and what you spend your time doing
and who you spend your time with you can
kind of be closed off into yourself a
bit don't like doing crazy things or
going crazy places which is just like
how I am you don't like causing drama or
being involved in anything stupid you
were just caught in the middle of a
misunderstanding I saw the whole thing I
was standing with Chris while you and
Mary went to get a drink and these two
girls I think like thought you guys were
someone else and you guys just asked
them what they wanted but they like
prodded back at you for some reason and
then it all just erupted and you were
just there in between it all trying to
stop it
soon Shannon left leaving Claire alone
in the hospital room for a while
Claire sat in silence thinking to
herself trying to piece everything
together it had been a little over a
week since she had awoken from her coma
unaware of who she was and what happened
now after she had talked with five of
the people supposedly closest to her
asking each of them who she was and what
had happened and why somehow she still
didn't have any idea
each person described her almost
completely differently often in complete
contradiction with each other but each
person had good reasons examples and an
obvious sense of certainty with what
they said Claire wondered to herself how
she could be all of those things they
described if they contradicted each
other what was actually true she
wondered to herself was it all true was
none of it
what is true
who was she
[Music]
this video was sponsored by fabulous
it's fascinating that most of us could
easily describe a few simple things that
we could do each day that would almost
certainly improve our lives eating
better sleeping better exercising
meditating reading and so on but yet we
don't do them or we try but we don't do
them very well or often the self-care
app fabulous is a unique app that uses
principles from Behavioral Science to
make these simple seeming but often
difficult habits actually simple and
actually stick by breaking down
long-term goals into small tasks and
trackable habits and by using guided
approaches and daily insights fabulous
works like a digital coach that can help
you sustain your motivation and make
your goals more achievable fabulous
offers two main approaches one is a more
self-guided habit tracking approach
which is best for the person who already
knows what sorts of goals and habits
they want in this approach you can
select and create habits and then use
fabulous notifications tracking function
and other features to help develop and
stick to them the second approach is a
more immersive experience with fabulous
dedicated program approach which uses
their behavior change programs habit
changing programs guided experiences and
content Journeys that provide extra
guidance and insights about how to go
about understanding and defining your
goals while providing additional help
along the way our quality of self is
truly built in major part on the
collection of things we repeatedly do
and so it is exceptionally important
that what we do repeatedly attends to
who we want to be start building toward
your ideal daily routine today by
clicking the link in the description
below the first 500 people who use the
link will get 25 off their premium
subscription with fabulous premium you
can create an unlimited number of habits
and take part in all programs and
exercises
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
foreign
[Music]